[Music]
so
so just transition fund is the first and
the very significant pillar
of the green deal we have a very
demanding decarbonization process in
front of us
that will affect people the cities the
regions in europe and particularly the
most intense in usage of of gold for
instance
and so we do need to make a transition
out of fossil fuels
and for that to happen we have to
support the regions we have to support
people we have to support the community
so that this transition can be
fair that's the why we call it the just
transition fund
at this moment uh at the current state
of the negotiation this will mean 17.5
billion euros
to support these transitions in the most
affected regions
the parliament demanded for much more
but still this is a very significant
amount and we hope to make a difference
in people's lives
in this transition that we do need to
tackle but we want to make it fair
we don't want to leave anybody behind
50 of the fund will only go to countries
that do commit
to neutrality carbon neutrality if they
don't
they will only get off of the money till
they really commit to that transition
and moreover it was our proposal from
the s d group
that about a fifth i mean 20 percent of
the fund
will be handed to the countries and to
the regions accordingly to concrete
achievements not just the commitment on
carbon neutrality but
concrete achievements in greenhouse gas
reduction in
concrete decarbonization processes and
results so
this means that you do need to deliver
results
if you want to have the funding of the
just transition fund so it's not just
about beautiful words
it's about actions towards the
carbonization and make it fair for
everybody